hey buzz feeders and bottom feeders it's
Tom Kenny the voice of Spongebob
Squarepants and this is Bill figure
Bucky I'm the voice of Patrick hi what
are we doing staring into your computer
right now we are taking a BuzzFeed quiz
by answering these questions this quiz
will divine which spongebob character
you are or which one you are most like I
can't wait to find out this question one
pick a rockin Bikini Bottom anthem to
sing it's your next karaoke night
that's another sweet victory and makes
me think of Adam Levine the campfire
song the fun song a ripped pants
the theme song over you know when that
might be good if there's drinks flowing
if the karaoke night is in a cocktail
situation a pirate sea shanty is always
a good way to go what is the best day
ever I mean if you pick that one would
with the writer get royalties that
you're right I go with that day ever I
wrote that song I'm gonna make two cents
on this answer you have to get out of
bed thinking that today is gonna be a
good day or else why why bother
can i really take the campfire sucks cuz
they wrote it right here so be easy to
spell ha ha ha pick the fruit you would
most like to call your undersea Oh would
you like to live in location Location
Location apple water
in a seedy neighborhood to pineapple
that's nice has that familiarity banana
ooh
dragon fruit or Nate oh yes tomatoes are
a fruit not a vegetable
wait a minute I'm gonna go with dragon
fruit bill sweet of the following which
random word speaks to you the most 1bo
imagination who blog least remember that
one
memories favorite direction chocolate
what chocolate I remember when they
invented chocolate hmm oh man I gotta go
with chocolate just cuz I like those two
crazy old ladies wouldíve it all wombo
combo which of your fellow bikini bottom
dwellers would you most enjoy spending
your day off with Tom Karen the computer
computer Larry the lobster Larry the
lobster spending my day off with bubble
buddy bubble buddy this is buff or I
prefer a long time thanks I love me some
Mary Jo Catlett a little I'm going mrs.
puff you're gonna go with mrs. puff yeah
Karen the computer I actually am married
to her in real life so if she did I
prefer that I keep my distance you gonna
do her Larry the lobster yeah he'd make
me go to the gym bubble buddy too
fragile you know Bill I agree with you
all I'm going to go with mrs. puff -
just because she is one of my favorite
characters on the show and she's nice
and she's been around the block man
she's on time in jail
pick your favorite instrument to play
and or listen to clarinet violin piano
acoustic guitar drums or moo-moos no
Patrick mayonnaise drugs you like drums
I hit the I hit and stuff memory rice
and stuff mayonnaise it's the best
sounding of the condiments and the
easiest to tune all right now her
favorite item from the following either
a krabby patty
ooh patrick secret box no food item
choco la a 10-gallon hat a possibly
stolen balloon or a krusty krab pizza
it's the pizza for you and me cause de
Grey oh man I'm gonna go a secret box
cuz that could have anything in it you
know the possibilities are endless and I
love a possibly stolen balloon cuz that
was such an awesome episode little
klepto you're a little clip D and
finally are you ready are you ready bill
never here are your choices I'm ready
I'm ready I'm ready I'm ready
that's choice one choice - ready for
what choice three oh no no choice for
ready to kill me buddy
ha ha ha all ready or not ha ha that's
good we ready for the secret formula I'm
in the courage what how could that be
yeah we're both mr. Krab's Squidward cuz
I've got guy get older and crankier
every year but did you do that shriek
you do the crab shriek no you're a
natural-born leader dedicated to your
craft with a k' get it like crap but
with the cake of Krabby Patties and a
hard worker through and through but but
what's weird about that it doesn't say
that you got mr. Krabs cuz you're greedy
or avaricious hmm it's because you're a
natural-born leader and a hard worker oh
I like it that's positive I like it you
are a natural-born leader and a hard
worker it just keep your paws off me
what yeah surprising I'm gonna take this
test again something must have gone
[Music]